INCLUDING ATTEMPTED HOMICIDE AND
HIS ARRAIGNMENT IS EXPECTED TO
BE SCHEDULED TUESDAY.
>> CHRISTINA COLEMAN LIVED FOR
US, THANK YOU FOR THE REPORT.
I WAS A GREAT REPORT FROM TINA,
A LOT OF QUESTIONS HERE.
WE KNOW TODAY THERE IS NEW
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SUSPECT,
DAVID, HIS STEPDAUGHTER IS
SPEAKING OUT SAYING THIS IS AN
ABUSIVE PERSON, HE WAS ABUSIVE
TO HIS CHILDREN, THE MOTHER OF
HIS CHILDREN, BOTH PHYSICALLY
AND SEXUALLY ABUSIVE.
SHE ALSO SAID THIS PERSON IS
BASICALLY A GOOD PERSON BUT HAS
A MONSTER INSIDE OF HIM HE CAN'T
CONTROL.
NONETHELESS IT'S PAINTING THE
PICTURE OF AN AND UNSTABLE
PERSON BUT THAT DIDN'T STOP
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA FROM
BLAMING RIGHT-WING POLITICS FOR
THE ATTACK.
LET'S LISTEN TO PRESIDENT BIDEN
FROM EARLIER TODAY.
>> YOU CAN'T CONDEMN THE
VIOLENCE UNLESS YOU CONDEMN
THOSE PEOPLE WHO CONTINUE TO
ARGUE THE ELECTION WAS NOT REAL,
IT'S BEING STOLEN.
ALL THE MALARKEY BEING PUT OUT
THERE.
>> WASN'T JUST PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THE MEDIA WAS ALSO ON THE ATTACK
RIGHT AWAY AFTER THE INCIDENT.
LET'S LISTEN TO THIS EXCHANGE
FROM MSNBC.
>> D INTRUDER CONFRONTED MR.
PELOSI SHOUTING WHERE IS NANCY,
WHERE IS NANCY?
THAT'S WITH THE INTRUDER GOING
TO THE HOLLYWOOD, PART OF THE
JANUARY 6 TOXICITY.
>> WHAT CLIMATE OF VIOLENCE HAS
BEEN CREATED IN THIS COUNTRY?
THE ANSWER, DONALD TRUMP, HIS
CANDIDATE AND PRESIDENT URGING
PEOPLE IN VIOLENT WAY.
>> LET'S TAKE THE DISCUSSION TO
THE TABLE.
GUESSING WHEN YOU FIRST HEARD
ABOUT THIS HORRIFIC ATTACK.
IT WAS HORRIFIC, I'M GUESSING
YOU MIGHT HAVE THOUGHT THAT THIS
WOULD BE TAKEN BACK TO JANUARY 6
AND TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> I THINK THE RESPONSE FROM
BIDEN AND MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
BASICALLY THE MOST PREDICTABLE
PART OF THIS SITUATION.
WE KNEW HOW LONG UNTIL THEY CAN
DRAW SOME DIRECT LINE TO
ANYTHING TO DO WITH
REPUBLICAN'S, CONSERVATIVES,
RIGHT WING, ANYTHING AND THEY
DIDN'T SKIP A BEAT, THEY WENT
RIGHT THERE.
THIS WAS A HORRIFIC ATTACK AS
YOU ARE SAYING, NO QUESTION.
WE WISH PAUL PELOSI WELL AND
HOPE HE GETS BETTER SOON BUT NO
MATTER WHAT, WE DON'T HAVE ALL
OF THE INFORMATION.
JUMPING TO CONCLUSIONS LIKE THIS
DOES NOTHING GOOD FOR ANYONE.
LET ME READ SOMETHING A DEMOCRAT
MAXINE WATERS SAID, IF YOU SEE
ANYONE IN RESTAURANT, A
DEPARTMENT STORE, GASOLINE
STATION, YOU CREATE A CROWD AND
PUSH BACK AND TELL THEM THEY ARE
NOT WELCOME ANYMORE, ANYWHERE.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER JOE
BIDEN CALLING HAVE THE COUNTRY
SEMI- FASCIST SAYING WE WERE A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY SO TO ALL OF
A SUDDEN JUMP TO THIS
CONCLUSION, VERY PREDICABLE,
TOTALLY UNHELPFUL, WE HAVE ALL
THE INFORMATION BUT THE
DEMOCRATS TO JUMP OUT SUGGEST
SOMEHOW REPUBLICAN'S TRUMP
GENERALLY SIX IS RIDICULOUS.
>> I WANT TO ASK DAVID ABOUT THE
TIMELINE HERE, WE HEARD ABOUT
THE TIMELINE IN CHRISTINA'S
REPORT, POLICE APPARENTLY
RESPONDED WITHIN MINUTES BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AROUND THE TIMELINE.
WHAT QUESTIONS DO YOU HAVE?
>> THE TIMELINE OF HER RESPONSE,
THREE MINUTES.
NOT SURPRISING.
TYPICALLY IN THAT NEIGHBORHOOD
AND IT JUST CAME TO SAN
FRANCISCO BUT I KNEW IT AREA,
POLICE ARE USUALLY STATIONED
THERE AND THEY HANG OUT IN THE
BETTER NEIGHBORHOODS BECAUSE OF
THE CRIME AND EXPANDING CRIMES
INTO THE MISSION DISTRICT AND
OTHER AREAS.
THE TIMELINE TIED WITH THE CALL,
THE STATEMENTS AND COMMENTS,
SPEAKING IN CODE, WHAT TYPE OF
ENTRY WAS MADE AND ALARM SYSTEM
ON THE HOUSE THAT DID ALERT
AHEAD OF FUN ONE, I WANT TO GO
BACK TO WHAT LORA SAID, I
STARTED LISTENING TO TALK
STATIONS LIKE HERE IN NEW YORK
AND THERE COMMITTING THE SIN OF
ONE FROM BLAMING REPUGNANCE
WITHOUT FACTS, NO SURPRISE BUT
OMITTING DIFFERENCES, THIS GUY
IS CLEARLY DELUSIONAL IN MANY
WAYS, DANGEROUS AND PROBABLY
NEEDS A LOT OF HELP
PSYCHOLOGICALLY AND IF YOU LOOK
AT HIS MANIFESTO BACKGROUND OF
WHAT HE BELIEVES IN, HE'S LIKE A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE GONE
AGAINST EVERYTHING AT ANY MOMENT
GOING FROM SOMETHING SO THEY ARE
DOING TO SERVICE BUT HERE WE ARE
TEN DAYS FROM THE ELECTIONS AND
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR DEMOCRATS TO
BRING UP THE SPECTER OF RACE,
MAGA, I DON'T SEE MAGA
PERSONALLY, WHAT'S WRONG WITH
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN?
BUT THIS IS BRINGING UP
SOMETHING AS NEGATIVE WITH A ARE
LOOKING TO LOSE AND IT'S WHAT
THEY ARE DOING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AT THE MOMENT THEY WILL USE AS
MUCH AS THE CAMPUS WEEKEND AND
IT'S A LIE TO SAY IT'S ONE OF
THE OTHER, EXTREMISTS ARE
OUTSIDE THE NORM.
>> LET'S LOOK AT THE CHARGES
SUSPECT FACES, HE FACES A SLEW
OF CHARGES FROM ATTEMPTED
HOMICIDE, ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY
WEAPON, ELDER ABUSE, BURGLARY,
SEVERAL ADDITIONAL MONIES AS
WELL.
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO LEE
ZELDIN WAS ATTACKED ON STAGE
WHEN HE WAS CAMPAIGNING FOR
GOVERNOR, QUITE A DIFFERENT
STORY WITH HIS ATTACKER, HE WAS
LET OUT OF JAIL AND BECAUSE
CONGRESSMAN LEE ZELDIN IS A
CONGRESSMAN, HE'S GOING TO FACE
FEDERAL CHARGES BUT LISTS LISTEN
TO LEE IS ALVIN'S RESPONSE, HE
TALKED TO NEIL THIS MORNING.
>> WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS TO ME,
MY FAMILY, OTHER PEOPLE LIKE WE
SAW YESTERDAY, IT'S A REMINDER
THIS CAN HAPPEN TO ANYBODY.
>> THE FELLOW WHO ATTACKED YOU
ON STAGE IN THE SUMMER, HE'S TO
BE RELEASED FROM CUSTODY IN A
FEW DAYS INTO AN ALCOHOL
TREATMENT PROGRAM.
>> WITHIN HOURS, HE WAS RELEASED
BECAUSE OF NEW YORK'S CASHLESS
BAIL LAW.
THE FED HAVE TO GET INVOLVED A
DAY AND A HALF LATER AND CHARGE
HIM BECAUSE I'M A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS BUT IF I WASN'T, HE
WOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN DETAINED
AT ALL, THE FED WOULDN'T GET
INVOLVED WITH THE CHURCH.
>> JOEY, WHAT YOU THINK PEOPLE
THINK WHEN THEY LOOK AT THIS?
DO THEY SEE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
WAY JUSTICE IS DOLED OUT?
>> EVEN MORE THAN THAT, SAN
FRANCISCO ASK WHAT I GET A
RESPONSE THAT QUICK WHERE I
LIVE?
LOCAL.
I CAN'T NOT GO BACK TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S WORDS A FEW MINUTES AGO,
THE IDEA -- LET'S BE
PLAINSPOKEN, IT'S EVERYTHING TO
DO WITH THE MIDTERMS IN A WEEK
AND A HALF.
THEY'VE HOPEFULLY GOT ABORTION
ON THEIR MINDS IN JANUARY 6 AND
ANYONE WHO WANTS A SECURE
ELECTION WANTS TO OVERTURN AN
ELECTION, IT'S ALL THEY HAVE.
THEY DON'T HAVE A POLICY TO PUT
OUT ONE ACCOMPLISHMENT.
THE MOST THEY CAN DO, THEY NEED
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT IT WAS
ORIGINALLY REPUBLICAN IDEA SO
THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ELSE TO
OFFER.
WE'LL TALK LATER HOW MUCH
HOT-WATER THEY ARE IN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SO WHAT DOES BIDEN DO?
USING'S THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
WHICH IS SHAMEFUL TO SPIN IT
BACK TO GENERALLY SIX AND THAT'S
AS MUCH AS HE HAS TO SAY.
THE PARTY THAT HAD PAUL WRITING
RYAN PUSHING BRYAN, PEOPLE AND
BIGOTS WANTING TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM SEXUALIZED DRAG
SHOWS, THE PARTY THAT SHOWED UP
AT THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
HOUSE WITH A FAKE BABY COVERED
IN BLOOD TO TALK ABOUT HOW GREAT
ABORTION WAS AND SAY NOTHING
ABOUT INCITING VIOLENCE TO
POLITICAL RHETORIC.
WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY THAT
DOESN'